[موسيقى]
يا
الحرب في أوكرانيا
كان لها تأثير ضئيل على
الاقتصاد السعودي
بسبب الروابط التجارية المباشرة الصغيرة
أه
الروابط المالية المباشرة لا تذكر وأيضًا لأن أه هناك
القليل
من واردات الحبوب والقمح
من تلك
المنطقة وهذا ما قيل
أه الأثر
على
الأثر غير المباشر للحرب في
أوكرانيا هو أن لديك سعرًا أعلى للنفط
وهذا أمر إيجابي للمملكة العربية السعودية
من حيث مساعدة فائض اقتصادها
و
[موسيقى]
توصياتنا للمملكة العربية السعودية
هي الحفاظ على زخم الإصلاح
أه  بغض النظر عن أه تطورات
أسعار النفط ،
أعتقد
أنه من المهم الاستمرار في
الانضباط المالي و
[الموسيقى] الضبط
المالي للمضي قدمًا
للتأكد من
الحفاظ على الاستدامة المالية
بغض النظر عما
يحدث لأسعار النفط أم أن
تقريرنا يوصي أيضًا
متابعة الإصلاحات الهيكلية
وهناك العديد من الإصلاحات التي
نفذتها المملكة بموجب رؤية 2030
من إصلاحات سوق العمل إلى
بيئة الأعمال إلى الرقمنة
وغيرها وتلك مطلوبة
لإطلاق العنان حقًا
لتنمية القطاع الخاص